We are on problem number
10 on page 489.
Stacy noted that she is both the
12th tallest and the 12th
shortest student in her class.
So let me write 12th down.
She's the 12th tallest and
shortest. If everyone in the
class is a different height,
how many students are
there in the class?
And these are the type of
questions that I just like to
make sure that I'm
not miscounting.
So she's the 12th tallest.
So what does that mean?
That means that there are 11
people taller than her.
So let's say from shortest to
tallest. So this is Stacy
right here.
And so, if she is the
12th tallest-- let
me put it this way.
If I said that she was the
first tallest, that means
there's no one taller
than her.
If she's the second tallest,
that means there's one person
taller than her.
If she's the third tallest, that
means there's two people
taller than her.
And likewise, if she's the 12th
tallest, that means that
there are 11 people taller.
Similarly, if she's the 12th
shortest, well, that must mean
that there are 11 shorter
than her.
So this is really just making
sure that you parse the words
correctly and count properly.
So if there's 11 shorter, 11
taller, and then there's
Stacy, well, that's
22 plus her.
There's 23 students
in the class.
And this is just to make sure
that you don't say, oh, 12
taller, 12 shorter, and say
25 or something like that.
It's just to confuse you
really, I think.
Problem number 11.
Image.
Clear image.
Invert colors.
Problem number 11.
Switch colors.
The quadratic function g is
given by-- this is just the
general way people write
quadratic functions-- is equal
to ax squared plus bx plus
c, where a and c
are negative constants.
Which of the following could
be the graph of g?
So I'm not going to even
look at the choices.
I'll just show you how I would--
if someone didn't even
give me any choices, and say,
well, if a and c are less than
0, what's this going
to look like?
So let's draw the x and y.
So let's say that that
is the x-axis.
Actually, I drew this--
let me edit, undo.
OK.
So let me draw the x-axis.
You might realize pretty soon
why I have to redo this.
The y-axis.
x, y.
All right.
So we know that a and
c are negative.
So c is the y-intercept,
right?
When x is equal to 0, we're
just left with g of
x is equal to c.
So c is the y-intercept.
So if c is less than 0, we know
that the y-intercept is
going to be below the x-axis.
It's going to be a
negative number.
We know that this is c.
That's where the graph
intersects the y-axis.
We also know it's going to be
symmetric around the y-axis.
Well, actually, we don't know
for sure that it's going to be
symmetrical around the y-axis.
And I could go into that in
more detail, but I won't.
But that's all we
need to know.
It depends what the bx--
this term-- is.
But let's just ignore
that for now.
And then we know that
a is negative.
So in general, you might want
to prove it to yourself, you
know the graph of y
equals x squared.
That opens up like this.
And the graph of y is equal
to minus x squared.
It goes down like that.
So a possible graph for this
would look like this.
The important thing is these
are the two things that you
know when they tell you
a and c is negative.
It's going to be a graph that
opens downwards, and it's
going to intersect the y-axis
in the negative area, below
the x-axis.
A legitimate graph also would
have looked like this.
It could have also
looked like this.
It didn't actually have
to be symmetric.
It depends what this
bx term does.
But if we look at the choices,
the only choice that
intercepts the y-axis below
the x-axis at a negative
y-intercept and opens
down is choice A.
There's only three choices
that open down, and only
choice A intercepts in
the negative area, so
the answer is A.
It actually looks eerily
like what I drew,
just out of the blue.
Next question.
Problem number 12.
OK, so they drew a square.
And I will draw a square,
because they drew a square.
And they say this is A, this
is B, this is C, D.
And this is P.
This is Q.
And out here is R.
I don't know where this
problem's going, but it looks
interesting.
Figure not drawn to
scale, of course.
In the figure above, ABCD
is a rectangle, with
BC is equal to 4.
AB is equal to 6.
P, Q, and R are different points
on a line, not shown,
that is parallel to AD.
So P, Q, and R are apparently
all on the same line that is
parallel to AD.
Well, I guess that is the
way they drew it.
So let me erase.
Let's just say this is Q.
That R is down here.
This isn't R.
So they're all on
the same line.
And they say the line
isn't shown, but
it's parallel to AD.
So let me draw that line.
So that line looks something
like this.
Let me draw it straight.
And on that line, you have
P, Q, and R, and it
is parallel to AD.
Good enough.
Points P and Q are symmetric
about line AB.
OK, so that means that P and
Q are equidistant from this
line, so that means that
this distance is
equal to this distance.
When they say P and Q are
symmetric around AB, you can
almost pretend like AB's a
mirror right here, and P and Q
are the mirror images
of each other.
Good enough.
And then it also says
points Q and R are
symmetric around line CD.
So we also know that
this distance is
equal to this distance.
Good enough.
What is the length of PR?
This is fascinating.
So let's say that this length
right here-- let me do it in
yellow-- this length is x.
Then what is this green
length going to be?
This green length right here
is going to be 4 minus x.
How did I know it
was 4 minus x?
Well, this distance
up here is 4.
So this is x.
This is 4 minus x.
Well, then this distance right
here is also going
to be 4 minus x.
And if this yellow distance is
x, then we also know that this
distance is x.
So the distance from P to R is
going to be the sum of all of
these, right? x plus x plus
4 minus x plus 4 minus x.
And I think you see where
this is going.
It's x plus x plus 4 minus
x plus 4 minus x.
These x's all cancel
out, right?
2x minus 2x.
And we're just left with 8.
And that's our answer.
B.
And you could've tried it out.
You could have assumed Q was
right in the middle, and it
would have worked out the same,
but you know for sure
that the answer is 8.
Next problem.
Image clear.
Invert.
I don't know if I'll
have time for this.
The price-- I get nervous when
I'm running out of time.
So I'm going to do this
in the next video.
See you soon.